[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bientôt ranger les soluces
[Musique]
je veux qu'ils vont
mais je ne viens pas bonjour ça
[Musique]
ma fille je les choisis avant
pris d'assaut
le monde il
[Musique]
ajouté
les garçons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça
les
oui je
si ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le temps pour la
bah
moi
jouy
entendu
jusqu'au bout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai une
dent
comme si j'étais en vacances
comme si j'étais un nazi les faits
étaient sans problème
beck
je suis
[Applaudissements]
c
[Musique]
m
à
mais cela
et
allez
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
raté
[Musique]
sinon
oui
je vois ça
je
j'ai mal
mais ça hamad ça
[Musique]
je peux ça ça
ça
[Musique]
jeunes
ça
à
l'egypte
suite
bonsoir
110 cas je vous avoue son temps des même
plus parler comme dalida bien ici si
vous voulez sinon on peut la faire un
tram c'est bien triste c'est super dans
la gestion c'était ça koné dalida mais
je me doute que cette bêta
oui mais bravo bravo alors si la bouffe
est attaché la brigitte bardot
de m'apercevoir que j'étais venu chez
monsieur a un passé ya pas photo
brigitte bardot
non je vois bien un débat merci beaucoup
sont dits oui on résiste pas et vous
faisiez la voix de brigitte bardot tout
oui tout à fait
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr voilà une destination des
nouveaux
[Applaudissements]